So, Teddy Roosevelt's son,
Theodore Roosevelt, Jr.,
joins the Harvard
Freshman Football team.
His first game,
the other team targeted him
because he's
the President's son,
and ... nose broken.
Like, right away.
Put a huge gash on his face.
So Teddy Roosevelt decided
that football's fantastic
but maybe a little bit
too violent.
Maybe we could calm it down
and, you know,
in his spare time
he was President,
so he ended
the Russo-Japanese War
and then was like,
"I'm also going to fix ...
I'm going to save football."
Anyway,
what was I talking about?
Teddy Roosevelt?
So Teddy Roosevelt called
this meeting
with the heads of the college
football powerhouses
and he was like,
"Look, guys, football.
Pretty violent, right?
Love the sport,
doing a great job,
let's not kill so many people?"
So the head coach of Yale,
Walter Camp,
who was known as the father
of American football was like,
"Um, don't talk about
my sport that way.
I made this sport, and we're
not going to change it.
Football is football,
suck it bro."
So the President was like,
"Well, this guy just told me
to suck it bro,
so I think the meeting
is adjourned.
I think the meeting
is adjourned."
And so they didn't come
to any sort of agreement
and at the end of that season
the newsboys were like,
"Extra, extra, read
all about it. 18 deaths."
I was going to say
serious deaths.
There are deaths that are like
... it's kind of funny.
"18 deaths and 159 fatalities.
Shit, fatalities means deaths.
18 deaths and 159 super serious
injuries from football
happening now,
exclamation point.
End quote.
Read about it. Or don't."
So Teddy invited everybody
back and he's like,
"Hey y'all, all this stuff
just happened.
Walter Camp,
I see you raising your hand.
I don't acknowledge you.
We have to change your sport.
I get that it's your baby,
but sometimes your baby sucks."
If you give birth to a baby
and you're like,
"Do whatever
the (beep) you want."
It's going to punch people
and people are going to die.
Your baby needs to be raised
properly in a decent home,
and the decent home is,
"Let's make some new rules.
So like, what if, crazy thought,
what if we make first down,
instead of five yards,
make it 10."
Then he was like, "What if you
took a ball and you threw it
instead of only just being able
to shove into each other
to move down the field?
Wouldn't that be wild?"
People were like, "Wait,
you want to throw a ball?"
"Like yeah, it's why balls
were invited, to be thrown."
Walter Camp was like,
"Okay, fine."
So basically after that meeting
there was like a national
standard for what football was
and it was great.
It was all great because
of Teddy Roosevelt,
and like, nobody knows that.
They just think,
"Teddy Roosevelt,
oh, president."
Or actually nowadays they go,
"Teddy Roosevelt?
Oh, you mean Franklin?"
Because we're young and dumb
and nobody reads
a goddamn book anymore.
Woodrow Wilson was
the president of America,
the United States of America.
Edith ...
Wilson was the goddamn
president's wife.
So Woodrow Wilson,
he had 18 months left in office
and he had a ... stroke.
His doctor was like, "Uh,
Woodrow Wilson has had a stroke.
A big stroke.
Like we can't move y'all stroke.
So what you gonna do?"
Edith was like,
"Well, who I love is this man
for who he is,
and who he is is a guy
who wants to be president
for some (beep) reason.
So if I don't ..."
Just ignore that.
If I don't ... Just ignore that.
"If I don't help him
be president,
what a kind of wife am I?"
The doctor was like,
"Uh, you gotta run the (beep)
country, because this
guy's out for the count."
So Edith was like,
"No problem, I got this.
Shut up, sit down,
I am in charge now.
Can I get my cheesy bread
I brought?"
Your what?
Cheesy bread that I brought.
Can we finish this part?
What part?
The part that we want to do.
I did it bad.
We're still doing it.
All right. Oh.
I don't want the bread anymore.
So Edith Wilson,
she told America,
"Hey guys, excuse me.
My husband,
the president, he's very tired
and he will be resting,
he's very tired,
saying he needs to rest."
She even went to Congress
and was like, "Hey, no big deal.
I'm giving him everything
you're saying in Congress,
I'm giving him all the letters,
the note things.
So, what do you guys
think of this rule
or a law or thing that we're
working on?"
They'd be like, "Whatever.
What do you think of this?"
Then she'd bring it to Woodrow
who was like, half awake,
and she'd be like, "All right,
well Congress was like,
'Blah, blah, blah.'"
He'd be like, "Uhh."
She was like, "Well, I guess
I'll compromise.
I'm just going to ...
make the ...
make the decisions myself."
So basically Edith Wilson
was first female president.
She ran memos
between Congress and him.
Congress is like,
"All right, what ...
what ... what is going on?"
So Congress picked this one
Republican senator, Albert Fall,
they're like, "Albert, go see
what his true condition is.
Go see what Wilson's
true condition is."
So Albert Fall shows up.
He's like, "Can we come in see
the true condition?"
She's not ...
stupid, she's like,
"Yeah sure, come on in."
So Albert Fall comes in.
It was like, "Yep, this is him,
making decisions every day.
Then I take the ...
Thank you honey,
and I take the papers from him
that I don't understand,
because I'm just
some dumb broad."
Edith's just propped up Woodrow
in bed, like waving like, "Hey."
They're like, "Oh okay, cool."
She's like, "Bye."
And then they leave.
That's how dumb government is.
Elvis writes a letter to Nixon
while on the plane.
They land and he drops it off
at the front of the White House.
It was shocking. No celebrity's
want to hang out with Nixon.
So when he reached out
they're like,
"Elvis wants to meet with you.
This can't hurt matters.
Don't you want to see
what Elvis has to say?
Why not?"
He's like, "Yeah, arrange it.
Yeah, I want to meet him.
Let's see what's going on."
Elvis comes in and Nixon
looks at him, he's like,
"This is kind of crazy man,
you dress really crazy, man."
He's like, "Hey, you have
your getup, I have mine, okay?"
Nixon's like, "Yeah,
I'm glad you came by.
I want to meet you.
Good to see you."
Elvis does the hard sell
saying he needs the badge.
"Well I care, man.
I care about what's going on
with these people
and I care about the hippies
and everything that's being said
right now, man,
it's terrifying."
People that are saying
things about you,
and the people that are
saying things about me.
That's why I'm happy
to be here, man.
But I need this badge.
This is so big for me,
I need it."
Nixon really takes it in,
kind of asks his aid.
He's like, "Can we do this?"
The aid comes back and says,
"I'm sorry, it's dumb.
You cannot get this badge.
Sorry Mr. Presley you cannot.
You have no qualifications
in our mind to have this badge."
"Sorry brother,
I'm loving it."
Nixon decides to give him
this badge.
So Elvis goes back
to get photos taken,
but then Elvis is a licensed
and registered federal
narcotics agent.